all right
Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas to you
Mary
Merry Christmas Lloyd Christmas too damn
I've had a Merry Christmas and then I've
had a damn Lloyd Christmas
you know where you chip your tooth and
you know you end up
just damn looking for your own [ __ ]
all day
and that's a toughie
that's a toughy baby when you find
yourself you hot on the trail of your
own [ __ ] that's
you know
that's that's not good that's not good
I've had that Merry Christmas and I've
had that Lloyd Christmas
you know I've had
I've had it just
follow
you know where you and your cousin just
sitting on the damn porch steps just
eating just just feeding each other
manicotti
you know I've had that [ __ ]
where somebody come by drive up by the
house give you a little sip out of their
smoothie cup
and they're not even a pedophile or just
a
just a damn good samaritan with a
blender
you know I've had I've had those kind of
days those kind of holidays
you know where you know
where some hottie watch it let you you
know
let you watch her breast feed a little
not for a long time just enough you know
where you play that song
um
Hallelujah just one play you know
because it's almost biblical you watch
that
you watch a baby getting
titted out
and you listen in a Hallelujah you know
where uh
oh bless Ye Merry Gentlemen
you know that oh
Christ the savior is
you listen to that [ __ ] and you watch
somebody breastfeed you know
that's there's something very
Christmassy about it
now you follow that lady and the child
back to the car back to their room or
whatever that's
you know that's not in the Bible cuz
that's
you know you write in your own Chapters
at that point you're gonna probably end
up
you know you're gonna end up in jail or
doing you know
on house arrest or something but um what
was I talking about Merry Christmas to
you
happy holidays I've had that Merry
Christmas and I've had that Lloyd
Christmas
you know I remember one time we got
uh
you know I used to go drink lean over
there my buddy
was a
manager
at a Chuck E cheese
you know he was a manager over there at
all
at a Chuck E cheese baby and
we go over there sometimes I would go
over there sometimes after his shift
and we drank a little bit of lean over
there
you know just leaned with just we get
leaned up damn I was [ __ ] veal bruh
I'd had so much lean I was just damn
whoo you cut me into some medallions
baby and sell me I was veeled out I was
lean
and he would turn the bat you know he
had control of the uh Chuck E cheese
band that played on stage
and he turned that [ __ ] up to damn 11
bro
and we'd watch them play just as you
know
we'd watch him [ __ ] play I mean he
could we could do um
free bird in about a little over three
minutes dude
he'd want I mean them [ __ ] would play
fast as they could bro fat they do we
watching free but I mean just
you know we but we'd play to the damn
Chef that whatever the chef his name is
Benny or something let me see
who's in the band Chucky
cheese band members
this oh
uh whoever oh yeah pascali the drummer
he was the chef
and we pl one time he we put you know he
cried he had his playing so fast the
[ __ ] the chef arm came off that [ __ ]
son
but that was uh that was a Merry
Christmas man
you know when you so get you know
you so you amped up so much a damn you
over there in the bank you know the
Chuck E cheese band is playing for just
you and a friend
and you're sitting there just sharing
problems and sharing Joy
you know in a strip mall over there
and it's a little I will admit it's
mildly there's a homoeroticness to it I
think if you go there
but if you don't it's just good men
being good men
but uh
man the world's so fast now isn't it
the world is so damn it's so dang fast
everything's just how fast can it go
the speeds the gigabytes
the modem the text the Wi-Fi the airdrop
you know I remember back back in the day
you had to run a note if you wanted to
know something you had to run a note
now they got direct message me you could
send the pope a direct message
I've done it I'll be honest
middle of the night bro
just hit the pope up where the hoes at
you know
and yeah I shouldn't do it but
you know it's things happen
um what are we talking about sorry Merry
Christmas guys that's what I'm telling
you
um
but yeah things go so fast
things go so fast you got to make a
moment if you want a moment now you got
to make a moment
you gotta make a moment
that's what I'm noticing
you know I noticed some of my
friendships some of my relationship they
just
they just you know
we'll make a plan you know I've had an
instances where I've made a plan to go
do something and I go do it but I don't
make it a moment you know
you know I might spend time with a young
lady
and I don't make I don't I you know I
don't make it a moment uh a mayor
and I'm kind of checked in I'm partly
I'm on my phone maybe I'm but I'm that
but it's like I don't I don't say hey
I'm gonna make this a moment
I'm gonna put some damn
I'm gonna kick the clock right get right
in the nuts right now
you know instead so I'll just go with
the flow of time
but I've been thinking about that about
if I want there to be moments in my life
I gotta make a moment
I gotta make them
and I find for myself I I want
everything to be perfect before
something happens that's how I am
I want everything to be look as soon as
everything gets all lined up
it's all perfect then this will happen
and by doing that I'm not really giving
I'm not really giving the Lord a chance
to tickle me you know I'm not really
giving and stay with me
I'm not ripped by by by saying okay I'm
not when as soon as this then this and
then this
you know as soon as I get my slippers on
my feet will be warm
I'ma go to Daddy's I'm gonna make a pot
pie
you know it's but only I ain't having no
pot pie to like do the other thing until
I do my you know
when I have my own plan Stay With Me
what I'm saying is I'm always I'm I'm
always waiting for everything to be
perfect before I live my life
I'm always waiting for everything to be
perfect
before I live my life
as soon as these things line up
I'm gonna live my life
man I'm so guilty of that
you know it's you know
as soon as it as soon as you know this
new medicine I'm using helps me and as
soon as uh this shirt I ordered come in
and as soon as I learn Spanish
soon as I learned Spanish really well
like I'm a you know a blue belt or
whatever in it but I I always want to
wait till everything's perfect you know
Dustin Poirier noticed that about me
and he said to me Point Blank he said
hey man you can't wait for everything to
be perfect to start living your life
you can't wait for everything to be
perfect
to start living your life
and that hit me
I mean he packs a powerful punch and
that mother he damn he hit me with a
damn word punt you know what a word hook
because I bet that's what I've done
my whole life has been like that
inside of me it has been as soon as it's
all lined up I'm going to show you
myself
as soon as I've got it all looking the
way I want I'm gonna show up for you
and for me
and man those were just powerful words
that hit me this year
and I'm not trying to preach at you or
anything I just you know I was thinking
the other day about
what has been kind of a a highlight of
my year something I heard this year
um what are some things that
that stuck with me
and that was that was a big one
he sent me a message and he said and
sometimes you have to shoot a friend
straight
there's a lot of time where you can sit
there and you can be that shoulder
but sometimes you gotta you know
you got to be that fist baby
and I'm not talking you know but act I'm
not talking homosexual uh
you know homosexualizing
I'm talking straight being straight
or being gay but I'm talking about being
a friend
you know
so anyway man that's that was something
that that was something that that
resonated heavy with me this year
that I can't wait I can't wait man
it's not all gonna I'm never gonna get
to that where everything's okay
where everything looks a certain way
and in the meantime I'm burning the best
time I do have available
I'm burning that candle up
I'm burning this candle down and I'm
saying as soon as it gets bright enough
or warm enough in here
I'ma show up
but the candle's getting smaller
it's a trap
and that was something that uh that
resonated with me this year
that was something that resonated with
me this year
um
I want to thank you guys yeah for being
a part of the show and being a part of
my life and
um
yeah it's just man it'd been a journey
and this year went fast you know
and if I want moments I gotta make them
I gotta put my cleats on
when I show up
and say hey right now this is going to
mean something
this is gonna mean something
because time doesn't have the feeling it
doesn't have as much it doesn't
time doesn't
time doesn't know how much we care
and even worse and sad it doesn't care
it doesn't care man and that's it's kind
of sad but it's just that's our
responsibility
to make something mean something
and the time to start doing that
the time was over the time is already
the time it's been time you know
so anyway that's enough I'm stepping
down just step down off my high horse
and I'm back into the world man what's
going on
doing well being grateful
you know I remember a buddy of mine
smoked so much crack one time and that
he um
his appendix burst
you know because I guess uh
I guess your appendix doesn't like crack
and
and he people hated him so much he
burned so many bridges he couldn't get
her out of the hospital
so we had to run he had to run to the
hospital
and damn if that isn't
you know I love the Olympics and [ __ ]
but dang if that's not an Olympic sport
a spleen splitted crackhead
doing you know
doing five kilometers to the hospital
cuz
oh I tuned into that baby
okay we're gonna get into some calls in
a little bit
um what's going on with me you know I
spent Thanksgiving over at Dustin
poirier's house I guess we're just
talking about Dustin Poirier
um
and look I'll tell you this people don't
know this about that fella
that he's a chef that fella is a chef
I mean dude this is that's Chef Boyard
damage bruh
dude he was I showed up he's you know
he's out in the yard I mean he was I
mean he battered he battered two fish
fillets bruh
and I mean he battered them [ __ ] dog
I saw he went at least two and a half
rounds with him
you know they had a tarpon and his coach
wouldn't throw in the towel
but damn he you know
and one red snapper they went the
distance but he won
but I mean look man that man
I went over there
and
um
and it was exciting you know but I mean
he had all of I mean this dude he every
two hours he was up all night
doing food
he so he would go in the uh I mean he
just had he had ovens and this and that
fire wood chipper
damn he had a uh somebody was cooking
the [ __ ] just visually just some dude
staring as hard as he could
he had some dude on PCP just staring
straight into a ribeye
just grilling that [ __ ] out from the
center cause
man he was but I mean at dude every two
hours he'd be up with a ham
I came downstairs one time he's over
there breast he's over there feeding hey
he's burping a ham in a chair I said
dang what's going on cut
that man like to cook right these
snapping peas he doing all I mean it was
crazy
he's singing he's over there snapping
peas and singing uh slave songs and
should I say what
this dude he really man he was this
guy's got a couple he's got some
generations in him
he had recipes I mean all kind of stuff
just everything man and it was I had a
great time I haven't done a solo episode
since uh The Gangs giving episode so I
wanted to touch base with you and let
you know what I did
um
and that's what I did man I had a great
time
um that was a lot of fun over there in
Youngsville
Diner in Youngsville Louisiana
and we got to go out there with the good
fight foundation and
um they gave out a bunch of hams bro we
was just Hamming people
every car rolled up you hit him with
that ham baby dang
so we met at this place that's called
praisons it's a restaurant and a lot of
people that works with the good fight
Foundation were out there
and that uh and the good fight
Foundation is a it's a Dustin poiries is
his charity function
and um
and you always wonder what does a
charity do people wonder it all the time
you know
and look man I went down there and it
was cool
it inspired me
because you know a lot of people that
work with good fights showed up uh the
Raging cave the Louisiana uh football
team showed up
um
who else Alan joban was down there uh
Cody a couple other UFC guys Cody verret
couple Fighters they came out
and cars would roll up and you'd hit him
with that ham baby
you'd ham them [ __ ] up dog
and they had everybody rolled up
some one lady come up she's smoking so
many you couldn't even see in there you
open the door in the store just throw a
damn ham just into the damn distance
I mean she was just look like damn
Voldemort in there
like Voldemort just belched in that
[ __ ] it was just all smoke like her the
hell set it on the seat
you throw that [ __ ] in there cuz
one dude his brakes wouldn't work he had
to just he had his window down and we
try to just ham just hit that ham
through the window bro
just ham and that be just you know hit
him with that ham Baby Bam Bam
everybody was up in that bed to all
people some people rolled through have
silverware right there you give them
that ham they tread cut that they they
divide that [ __ ] up right there
it was wild man but it was awesome
it was a good experience and um
and yeah man uh that was fun and then
I'm just been I was in LA working on
stand up had some great shows thank you
to everybody that came out to see some
of those shows some were a little rough
but uh but they've been getting really
better
man I'm just really enjoying being back
on stage
and yeah I've been feeling better you
know I've been feeling better
in fact you know what I'm gonna say I'm
gonna go out on them I'm saying I've
been feeling good
I've been feeling good man
and it's funny because so much I spend
so much of my life feeling bad like you
know depressed all that I don't even
know how to do it
or I forgot that it's it's okay
I start feeling good
and I it's I got a call hey is it okay
if I feel good
you know
hey if you look at me do I look you know
I look crazy I just look like I'm
feeling you know
that [ __ ] I you know I feel good
I feel good man
and this is wow
yeah wow man that I feel good baby
man
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
that's right you know I've had moments
in my life where I'm struggling I can't
get out of my brain
it's like I can't get out of mud but the
mud or my is my own thoughts my own
feelings I'm stuck down there
it's quicksand and it's inside of me but
it affects the outside of me
it's pretty interesting how that works
well better help
they're available
because life doesn't come with a user
manual
and when it's not working for you
better help is there
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 of the
time
plus it's affordable yep
it's affordable
and if it's uh if if you don't like your
therapist you can get a new one that's
what I like you're not sure about your
therapist or it's not working hey switch
to another one
you know you can do it on the phone you
can do it on Zoom
um
and we can have you with a therapist in
no time better help us connect over
three million people with licensed
therapists it's convenient and
accessible anywhere
that's right no waiting rooms no traffic
no endless searching for the right
therapist just fill out a brief
questionnaire
to match with a therapist if things are
aren't clicking you can switch in a
moment
learn more and save 10 off with your
first month at betterhelp.com
slash t-h-e-o that's better
help.com Theo you know life um it gets
tough
and when it does there are solutions uh
better help
oh and one right one amazing thing that
happened was uh I got to see Roseanne
Barr
now for those you don't know Roseanne is
a um is an iconic female comedian
and she's I mean she been through it all
and we hope that she will come on the
show sometime
um
but I'm on stage at The Comedy Store and
I did and honestly I did well
and I'll tell you why I did well because
I do well
I'm gonna go ahead and say that
because I don't say that enough
that when I work hard
I do well
and I was doing well knock knock who's
there well
I was doing well dude if you came in the
room you saw two things it was naked and
I was one of them and I was doing the
other one the other one was well
because I was doing well
I was doing well baby and um
and I started I'm up there I'm doing
well and I hear this this laugh
I can't do it justice but it's just she
it's only they only made it in her
you know sometimes God makes some things
and they put it into one thing
like a Cool Ranch Dorito ain't nobody's
got that
nobody's got that
God dang it's good
and I re you know that's and she's got
that she's just she only her
only her has a Roseanne laugh and I
heard it
I heard it in the back of the room
and man my child but we SP that was the
one with the time my family got along
was that half hour sitting right there
as soon as that it show ended it was on
again
it was back into our Vietnam baby but
when that show was on
that was our Foxhole
so to get to make her laugh I mean she
laughed the whole time and it was just
man it was special it was written it was
real something real for me
something real for me dude I wanted to
just break open a can of my own dick and
eat it
you know
because it meant something to me
Merry Christmas to you guys I hope
you're feeling loved I hope you are
feeling
um capable
I hope you're feeling
that we can't wait for everything to be
perfect
to live our lives
we cannot
um what else I don't even know if you
guys can hear me on this microphone I
hope this microphone's working
these headphones are not working
so I can't hear myself but that's okay
we got a lot of calls that came in
um
we had some news that came in
um
Phoenix cop
accused of making porn while on duty
a phoenix officer is being investigated
for allegedly making and distributing
porn
while he was on duty and working from
home
um the officer has allegedly been
disseminating adult videos starring
himself through a public Twitter page
using the handle Rico Blaze okay I like
that
Spanish
uh
that's it okay and it seemed like a
brother this looks like a
black gentleman oh yeah he is
okay uh
yeah it's a black gentleman right here
he'd been running between Phoenix and
Los Angeles
um producing X-rated videos
uh I don't know if it says he did it on
he was on home Duty
I don't see where it says he did it on
duty but I will say this we are in a
Time
where of course people need two jobs
we just had a police officer on
the trauma that they go through
the responsibility
now I'm not saying every police officer
is built for the job I'm not saying that
I'm not saying that there aren't bad
police officers
but I'm saying this
that we learned firsthand
that that job they are the the drain
catch for so much stress and turmoil
in the world
that if they want to look if that man
wants to you know
come in his gun or whatever I
I you know he should be able to do it
if that may you know if this if he wants
to bust a
you know I think they should let him
bust Two Nuts a week or something if
they're cops
if they're copping or whatever
especially if nobody's in the if they
don't have a partner
I mean after with what these guys go
through I think we should pay somebody
pay a criminal to hand them off or
something
I mean these guys have they go through a
lot these men and women
so I'm not shocked and people need two
jobs nowadays you telling me that this
guy
for the four or five hours when
nothing's going on
he can't protect and serve what's the
serve part
he's serving Wayne or this fella
now if he's secretly recording and doing
that sort of thing and selling it I
don't think that that's good I'm just
saying that if he's able to
do it you know do a traffic stop
and then go get go get a cat out of a
tree you know what I'm saying boy
then let him
if he's able to do all of that and then
get back over
and stop a bank robbery then good
people need two jobs nowadays you have
teachers that have only fans and we're
firing them that's the sad part
that is the sad part now you know good
and well to say this dude makes his name
in pornography which I don't I don't
like pornography
but say he makes his name in pornography
and he shows up on the scene and there's
two dudes fighting
one of them they gonna stop fight
because they're worried this dude gonna
he gonna [ __ ] him down
if I know some dude really can really do
really do hammer time sex
he can do serious you know construction
worker dick throwing you know what I'm
talking about nail gun HVAC if he's got
all of that just built into his [ __ ]
that thing runs on diesel
then I I'm like I'm
I'm gonna do I'm gonna take I'm gonna
take orders and get home safe that's
what I'm gonna do
so I think we probably need people like
this
we need people like this
what else do we have in the news that's
interesting
um
[Music]
Utah senator introduces Bill to Outlaw
all porn Nationwide
Utah Republican senator Mike linger's
build Outlaw porn Nationwide
um
you know
the United States does not currently
have a national definition of obscenity
Lee is essentially arguing
that
he's a member Lee is a member of the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day
Saints
you know I I have to admit I think that
this would behoove people
this would help
I think that if this the
I think this business has ruined it's
now look I'm not saying I haven't
spent time with pornographers
I haven't watched almost
I'd say I probably watched
a quarter percent of the porn that's out
there
in my time
but
it's you know it's you see some of it
it's just you know the people their
holes are open and they're just
catching a cold you see one woman you
know
her butt is so open she's got to be
she's gonna catch a cold I feel like
sometimes you see some of that it's just
some of it's graphic
and I don't think it's helpful
I don't think that it's helpful
I don't think it's a long-term positive
play for society I really really don't
um
so I'm curious I want to I want to peek
a little bit more into this let me know
what you guys think about that hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
we're going to do a great call at the
end of this we're going to call somebody
I'm excited about it
um so we'll see we'll see what he says
uh about that pornography
um what else let's get into a few calls
let's get into a few calls that happened
man
I don't know what to do right now but uh
my uncle's got a bobcat
oh hell yeah
and that's a real Uncle
homework
it's like a pet and uh
man that thing's been coming around for
about two months now and uh
I'm gonna tell you right now
it gets Wild
because he's from the wild
oh yeah
look I'll tell you this man The Jungle
Book it ain't a book it's a damn
librarian son
The Jungle Book is a it's a Anthology
it's it's a billion chapters long baby
you gotta remember that an inch worm got
the same [ __ ] in it that a leopard got
in it that's all connected daddy gang
well
I'm telling you Dave I come home the
other day
and he was over there he snatched my
head off my head like real man
I told my Uncle I said you can do
something
so we figured it out they get some
jerked off every month and a half
175 dollars
to get that little Bobcat jerked off God
that's beautiful man
oh that's beautiful
you know uh
that Utah senator is not gonna like that
I'll say that
and I don't condone usually humans
pleasure an animal
there's videos out there they got a man
they called him what a you know and a
man and a dog dating
in a park
and they you know
I don't condone it when uh
if uh I don't condone that kind of stuff
but look if this is a bobcat if
something's gonna kill you if it doesn't
ejaculate
then you got two choices
die
or service that animal baby
nobody thinks you're a pervert if
something's going to kill you
and you make it e-jack
and then it doesn't kill you
that ain't
you know some kind of animal gay or
whatever
that's safety bub
ba that's damn safety dude
other than that he's good to go I just
want to let you know and thank you for
that man thank you for letting us know
I'll tell you this I'll tell you this
if they passed a
thing around my building a chart or
something you had a guess or check yes
or no
and these don't even work I don't know
why I'm wearing them if they pass that
thing around my building they said hey
there's a there is a bobcat in the
building
and and if it doesn't ejaculate
then every six weeks somebody gonna lose
a [ __ ] thumb homie
somebody gonna lose an elbow somebody
gonna lose a damn coccyx
you know what I'm saying Richard gonna
lose an eyeball baby
Libby gonna lose a Libya you know what
I'm saying bruh
then I say hey sign me up cut
I'll go first
I'll reach into the box you know
I put on a burn on one of those burn
proof mittens and reach into the box
you know in glove that little pecker out
because that's who I am bro
I'm working for God baby
all right let's take one more call or
two that came in
here we got a rapper named suggestion we
had an episode with young gravy if you
didn't get to hear it
um and we're excited about some great
episodes in the new year if you know
someone who would be a great uh
regular person job episode
you have a candidate for hit the hotline
let us know
[Music]
985-664-9503 or go to the website
the theovan.com there's ways you can
submit a video of them you know let us
know we want to get uh unique people on
who are good at communicating and
just have a interesting personality I
know that's a big question everybody
knows somebody but
be realistic
um here's a rapper named suggestion came
in
at the other man just listening to you
and uh young gravy this morning on the
way to work
thought a good rapper name I don't know
I usually whenever I call you I usually
call you daddy's on
or uh maybe 30p I like all dirty P make
you think you got a little something
swimming around in that key glass you
know what I mean oh hell yeah dirty piss
or biscuit piss they used to call me
you know when I was young I ate so many
carbs we didn't have a lot of meat at
the house
so we'd eat a lot of carbs dog
and if mom was going out or heading off
she would sometimes throw a can of
biscuits in there and start them [ __ ]
and our job was to end them [ __ ] in
them biscuits before they burned
and they used to uh
and I'd eat so many of them
you know they call me a biscuit piss
because my urine would smell
like
um those uh
Pillsbury
my urine would smell like those
Pillsbury God that was a [ __ ] good
time man
what else
uh so biscuit piss would be a good one
let me take one right here
what's up do you I just
[ __ ] man I forgot what I was gonna say
but
I don't know I was just watching videos
on you and your you talking about the
relationship with your dad and you
and it just kind of got me thinking
and I feel like I need to just talk well
thanks for the call brother
you can do that man that's that's good
you know thank you onward but
basically my dad left when I was nine
I'm 16 now I just feel like I feel like
I missed out
on my cabin up I guess the father figure
or just like a male role model
and so
I don't know I feel like I just lack
confidence
to myself because uh I feel like I've
never had anybody to
everybody's going to show me the way and
just teach me how to
I don't know man
I
I don't know
I feel you brother thank you for the
call man
uh I appreciate you sharing yeah I can
relate to that I feel like I missed out
but the the truth of that feeling I
think is it's they missed out
they missed out
you know in but we take it on ourselves
because that's the only way we know it's
obviously if our parent left or wasn't
there for us there must have been
something wrong we did there's something
wrong with us that's human that's the
nature of a child
something happens wrong in the world
well it must have been me I didn't do
enough
I wasn't enough
if I was only perfect my father would
have stayed if I was only this my if
only you know
and it's it's a it's it's it's it's it's
disappointing that your father wasn't
able to
you know
sometimes it's not even that he couldn't
or he didn't it's just something inside
he never got it he wasn't able to
you know and I'm so so I'm sorry
you know I'm real sorry
um
but I don't want you thinking that you
didn't deserve those things
you know
that you didn't deserve to be
stuck around for
that you didn't deserve to be loved that
you didn't deserve your dad to come and
just put his hand on the back of your
neck
and pull them in close by you
and kiss you on the head or tell you he
loved you
you deserved that
okay you deserved that
you know what I'm sorry that kind of
[ __ ] gets me animated man
because it's how you can't it's hard to
replace that
and I know exactly what you're I I'm
sorry I don't know exactly
I can relate sometimes I feel like to
what you're saying yeah man I didn't I I
never knew I never looked enough time in
my my dad's eyes I didn't know how
appropriate I noticed in my life I've
had trouble knowing how long to look
into a man's eyes when I'm talking to
him
because I didn't get the training
dads don't realize that that's that's
where your son gets the training of how
long do I look into a man's eyes when
I'm talking about something serious when
I'm you know
I never knew I've always had this thing
I'll look away a lot of times
because I don't know what the [ __ ]
proper amount of time is
to connect with someone without them
thinking that I'm
scared uh without them thinking that I'm
overconfident
that's where you learn all that [ __ ]
yeah nobody taught you how to stand up
for yourself
nobody all that [ __ ] man
I'm sorry bro
I'm real sorry and just know that you're
not alone in that
you know and there is a group out there
[Music]
um
children
there's a there's a there's a group
called adult children of Alcoholics and
I'm not saying your father's an
alcoholic but though they have a the
yellow book and uh the way that that
that all the the steps in there can be
helpful to Guys Like Us
dude I was when I would get friends I
would be so like
I would attach myself so much to my
friends there was times where I was like
man disease my does my friends think I'm
being gay
just because I don't know how to relate
to another man that much without you
know I don't know what you share what
you do I don't know what's going on
you know
I would remember I'd give my friends
extra hugs I would hug my friends my
male friends I'd hug my female friends
too
I'd hug that booty I'd hug them titty
but for the men some of them might give
him extra you know because I was every
time I would get a chance with a buddy I
just want a little piece of that
relationship with my father
I wanted a little piece of that can you
know and I would get you just an extra
fist bump an extra just you know I would
need it I wanted an I just wanted a
little bit
and I would siphon it off of other small
relationships
but just take care of yourself man
it's a long road you'll figure this
stuff out
that you're aware of it is important
some of that stuff's going to be a
battle and that's one of the things
that's happening in our world
you know it's happening a lot and it's
just some part of society that's going
on up it could be just American I don't
know enough about the world to know if
it's just an American symptom
um
but you're not alone bro
and it's a battle
um
but
you can't eat
but you got this man
you know you'll figure it out you got
this
and uh more people probably can
associate to that sort of thing than you
than you maybe realize I don't know but
I love you baby
praise God baby gang I'm upstairs
this holiday season get the best deal in
Wireless and that's through mint mobile
that's right when you switch to Mint
mobile and buy any three month plan you
get another three months for free
as the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only mint mobile
lets you order and activate from home
with esim while saving tons on phone
plans starting at just fifteen dollars a
month it's the perfect time to switch to
Mint mobile if you if you're considering
getting a cheaper phone plan
mint Mobile's best offer of the Year
this is it by any three month plan get
three months for free all plans come
with unlimited talk and text and
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mint Mobile plan and
switch easily and effortlessly
or if you need a new device for a
limited time get six months of free
service when you buy a select device and
plan for a limited time by any three
month mint Mobile plan and get three
months more for free
by going to mintmobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mintmobile.com Theo cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com Theo
all right ah you know we like to talk to
miracles on this show and um if you know
a miracle if you are a miracle if you
have someone in your family or a life
that has been a miracle has an amazing
story
uh hit the hotline
985-664-9503 we want to uh talk to a
miracle right now you guys may remember
this call that came in what's going on
the Rat King Hey Big Dog uh my name is
Julian Torres dude back in 2010 dude I
stepped on a a bomb lost both my legs in
Afghanistan
and uh since then dude I was like kind
of Kilimanjaro dude I
um I don't know Mandy I like to think
that I'm getting after it you know
um but yeah man like I see some crazy
[ __ ] uh
when I got blown up and stuff like that
man um I don't know man I'd love to tell
you the story man if you're willing to
hear I'm a huge fan
oh what's going on what's up big dog
baby what's going on gang gang baby
what's up dude where are you
dude I'm in Southern California baby boy
hey man bro far from your uh do you know
where ocean side's at oh yeah he's by
cocaine over there
oh really dude uh well you know what
they say about Oceanside right uh-uh
it's a sunny place for shady people oh
I believe that bro I believe that
so you join the Marines you're stationed
where
uh dude so I joined the Marines and
before we go any further I just want to
say what's up to all my boys in
segmentality six Marines gang baby hey
baby boy uh
and um because those dudes were the ones
that really uh out of Lejeune North
Carolina they're the ones that that put
Humpty Dumpty back together you know if
it wasn't for those dudes man if there
wasn't for those dudes bro like
I'm just a ghost you know what I mean
damn cuz yeah bro dude and what's crazy
dude and like what I think a lot of
people don't and you know like first I
mean
I'm a huge fan dude and I'm a huge fan
because like you're so like some things
you say and I'm like oh damn dog come on
baby boy you know but
for the most part dude I think you're
the realest dude on the internet Doug
the most authentic the most honest
um and I strive to be like that dog I
strive to be like that you know
um it's not always pleasant but uh
you're doing good man thanks bro
thank you man I appreciate that yeah I'm
trying my best you know it's tough to be
alive these days it's tough for
everybody to figure out
um and I appreciate you spending time
with us man and coming to us like you
know with this a real scenario that's
had that happens to so few people in the
world and then you get to live through
it I mean there's got to be like that
has to leave you with so many feelings
um and we'll get to that in a second I
just want to get down it's kind of
exactly kind of what happened if you can
take us through kind of the day so
you're stationed with your platoon it's
called
yeah I do so like uh so I'll just tell
you I'll just tell you
I'll tell you the story and then you
could ask questions you know okay
um and it dude like there's no rules man
if you if you wanna it's so important
that people ask about these uh these
these stories and these incidences
because
um it's a part of like our history you
know what I mean and I feel like if we
don't
um talk about it uh then the dudes that
didn't make it back home
there's their sacrifice bro is this like
it's like whatever you know what I mean
like it's disrespectful
yeah it almost is man it's like because
if we're not talking about it we're not
even honoring that it was a part of our
time
100 dude and it's tough dude and and
it's not even it's not even comfortable
for me to even share deep but like it's
bigger than me
right you know what I mean like you know
I mean it's it's like it's like it's
almost as if God like plucked me out and
was like you're going to experience this
and I want because like
I got you know I got the ability to
share I got the ability to talk about it
you know I got the ability right you can
handle this you can handle this wow
yeah and um that's powerful dog it is
dude it is and it blows me away like
like no pun intended you know
[Music]
but it just like you know when you think
about it dude it's just like it has to
be that I was selected because he
figured like I have a 10 inch shoot
and it's probably like what four inches
wide
and I stepped on something that's thick
as a ruler
you know and I'm walking on the earth
dude what are the odds of that foot
landed on that part
and I lose both legs and nothing else
dude you know what I mean I got my
genitals I got my guts I got my mind you
know like you know what I mean so it's
like how does that happen Beauty and it
you know sometimes you gain more than
you gain more than you lose you know and
you know what I mean uh I mean I can
only imagine you know I mean it's funny
you know it's like we've only spoken
with one other person that's kind of a
miracle and it's kind of different I
mean it felt I got hit by a train he got
trained up but I would yeah
right but yeah he got blasted by a train
and he said he wanted to he ready to run
it back baby you know what I'm saying
like he said that there's some
I think there's a greater currency
in existence
that we can't really put our hands on I
think as Americans we've gotten far away
from it with our society it's been you
know in some ways we've taken a detour
in some ways there's some currency that
we don't really know sometimes we can
feel it and some people get closer to it
and um it feels like some of that maybe
is what you're talking about
um but yeah man so so you watched
July 15 2010
uh we were in margin Afghanistan
um it's in the Hellman Province and that
I'll just talk about that particular day
because I mean we could bid on a whole
podcast and talk about the old
deployment but um I was only there for
like two and a half weeks man of full
combat operations
and um we were just walking through
the way it was designed man it was
um if you could imagine like a cornfield
and but it's not corn it's like opium
dude or or or or not yeah it's opium and
weed and you know they're growing the
dark arts over there if you know what I
mean oh yeah and um uh
we just I I cross over these two little
uh fields
and my buddy you know Andy Powell says
you know from what I can remember it
says oh there's a
there's an indicator
a little piece of you know uh cloth or
whatever I still don't even know what it
was really but he said there was an
indicator so he halted the patrol
and uh we started we took up and
obviously I was the closest one to like
the junction so I was like me being a
sergeant of Marines I was just like hey
man I'm not gonna ask
someone else to go do the heavy lifting
you know what I mean like if you're
going to be a leader you gotta you gotta
shovel [ __ ] too you know and what's the
junction when you say a junction what
does that mean
so that so there was there was two
properties joining together and they
were separated thanks man they were
separated by uh little canals
there was two canals you know what I
mean so I had a crossover
um both of those to go back and look at
you know looking for at the time we were
fighting like
you know uh sniper positions we were
finding machine gun positions
um the I the IED threat the bomb the
improvised explosive device threat was
like in the trees we got Intel that they
would be putting them in the tree so I
was looking all over the place but I
wasn't necessarily looking for an IED on
the ground you know and
um so there was uh 11 guys I was number
11 in our little stick our little
formation
our line
and then I was number 12 when I crossed
over it again
and then on the 13th time is when it uh
uh
I remember looking down and I remember
like the the
[Music]
the
light from the kinetic energy of the
blast just like enveloping me man
and then I felt all the little Pebbles
on my face
and I remember like making a little
sound of just stepping on that bomb do
the little sound that I made it was like
a
you know what I mean and then uh what
what what what made it what confirmed it
that I was I was the one that got hurt
was it shot me straight up in the air
and I saw my shadow from an aerial view
on the ground no way
and I was like you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me dog I'm it I'm the I tag
you're it damn
come on man and so so you could see so
the sun you were blocking You Could See
Your Shadow and you're like oh my God
this happened to me
yeah and so you were able to have that
thought you were able to have that
conscious thought oh my God this
happened to me wow 100 yeah man and then
I landed on my face oh and I remember
like I remember taking out the dust out
of my mouth dude and um
uh and I remember just immediately
thinking about my friends being like
dude I don't want
I want to be strong for them I want to
be
um I want to be like tough for them
and I don't want to show like I don't
want to wince or cry you know
um because they don't need an audio
track to this movie that they're going
to be with for the rest of their lives
you know what I mean
and uh
you know that's pretty selfless of you
and thank you for saying that man but uh
the the dudes the thing that you
experience in combat that nobody really
talks about
is the unconditional love you have for
your brothers dude or your sisters you
know what I mean I didn't have no female
Marines by me man but
um it was all dudes you know I mean so
and it's like it's the tenderness of
love that like a mother would give to
her child you know what I mean and um I
was a machine gunner dude so as a
machine gunner you get attached
uh to like a regular like uh infantry
man squad you know and
um
um because you're like a duty expert
this is your specialty weapon right
you know what I mean and so do you were
you did you stay conscious the whole
time
the whole time dog the whole time and uh
um you would appreciate this apartment
dude like when you talk about like your
dad and like your mom and like you being
like uh if I I could have appreciated my
dad more if I didn't judge him so hard
you know what I mean like I felt that
bro like it's so true dude like
I think a lot of times these things
happen to us and right away we want to
put judgment on it
you know instead of just seeing it for
what it is and being like okay man this
is my [ __ ] sandwich I gotta eat wow okay
man you know
pasta dressing or past the late chips
hey man like let's just make the best of
it damn cuz
you know what I mean well that's a
powerful attitude because I don't know
if a lot of people are gonna have that
um dude I got to give credit too dude uh
my wife man you know what I mean like
you're um so you were married when you
were in when you went in wow yeah man
I've been married I've been married to
my high school sweetheart huh dang dog
pervert
hey bro
my senior uh my senior prom bro dang cuz
that's nice
and is your wife are you Latino or no uh
yeah man oh that's cool man yeah I think
are you guys Mexican or what kind of
Latino is it
Mexican baby yeah I would like to be
Mexican
you said that before Doug yeah I think
maybe next time you know I don't know
how it you know exactly what happens but
I could do it I think I would dig it man
oh yeah dude it'd be [ __ ] fun
it is fun it is fun and it's tasty oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah if I everywhere I show up
there's chips I'm [ __ ] cool as hell
dog you know
yeah when you see those guys [ __ ]
that all of that [ __ ] those dudes
dancing those old dudes yeah yeah yeah
um well take me through a little bit
more of this so I want to know what is
some of those moments like what goes on
there when you're so you're awake and
this is happening man are you still able
to be a leader because if you're in a
leader position I'm sure it's tough
because you're supposed to be a leader
and now you are in a predicament that
most people would say this is you know
how could you be a leader right now so
when it happened dude you know what I
thought my first thought after I was
like yo I'm hurt
my boy started working on me my next
like real thought about myself was my
warring days were over
like I would no longer be a warrior in
the sense of life
you know what I mean it would be you
know it would be
now dude the war is right here between
my ears you know what I mean like
that's the war dude that's the
battlefield you know I mean and to be
honest with you it's the greatest
Coliseum the greatest Battlefield ever
created man you know I mean because
you're stuck with yourself you know what
I mean when you say stuff like that dude
like it's so you know the one time you
were saying um you go uh that you're
just sick of making all these decisions
sometimes you just need a break from
yourself you know you're like okay
someone else you know like you know but
we can't and we're with ourselves every
day Duty you know it really matters what
we tell ourselves dog it really matters
it's like
um hey man feeling down you know if
we're feeling down and out dog that's
that's okay you know what I mean like
it's okay bro like you know we can we
can find it like this is only temporary
you know what I mean like this is only
and like to be honest with you man like
um use like you like you bring this out
of me you know what I mean like because
you're so authentic you're so like oh
thanks man well yeah you know I mean
like you're you're like well it's bright
you know what you did is brave I mean we
just had a guy call in a few minutes ago
he's like his dad left when he was a kid
and he just he said I never learned how
to be a man you know and it's just
there's so many guys out there who you
know we're all everybody's going through
[ __ ] and so you know you sharing your
story it's like
you know we're all out here trying to
survive man
um bro dude do you want to know how I
found you the first episode yeah
was when you when you when you brought
in Santa Claus bro oh really yeah dude
uh so uh I'm from Modesto so like
probably like Stockton uh-huh oh yeah a
lot of missing people up there dog hey
everybody up there is [ __ ] missing
dog damn
if Santa's like hey man like Bobby's
address isn't right you know I mean
nobody's here Bobby ain't here yeah
where's Bobby bro and that was the
realest Santa bro that dude I think man
we need to bring him back yeah bro I
it's so funny I went
I got a date so I went this week I got
some trying to get some nice stuff from
my place to look at like trying to make
it look like I'm [ __ ] you know part
of the holidays and [ __ ]
so far I'm at this oh dude I'm at this
Christmas store I'm buying like
different [ __ ]
and it's all women in there bro so sad
and uh and I saw Santa's in there and
one of the dudes doing the pictures with
Santa that he recognized me he's like
dude I saw you on Joe Rogan will you
come get a picture with Santa dog it's
all [ __ ] in there getting me and
Santa putting up gang signs
oh man
um I have this question for you I have
this question for you how
when you have Times Like Christmas you
have times like
um
did you have moments where it was hard
for you to say I just have to keep
living my life right now I can't give in
to the toughness of this I you know I
can't
you know we started off this episode
talking about how we can't wait till
everything's perfect
for us to live our lives you know that's
so true Doug and I just wonder what some
of you are like what what is some of the
experience like that you've taken away a
little bit I know that's a huge question
and we can get into more of this later I
want to walk through a lot of it again
I think that um
do like you know like
if I had to if I had to say like like
there was a lot of times where I felt
guilty
for going to Christmas or having
Thanksgiving because my buddies who who
are dead they don't get to have that
opportunity anymore you know I I felt
guilty falling in love with my wife or
being intimate with my wife
uh you know or holding my kids kissing
on them and loving on them and being
like my boys never get to do this some
of the dudes that got killed were
fathers bro and their kids that's it you
know what I mean it's just like
you know I think about that stuff all
the time you know and a lot of times for
me dude it's just like I had to figure
out sometimes dude like
sometimes it's easier to know
how to live when you sometimes you're so
hurt and you're like dude like I'm so
broken I can't do this I can't do that
but you know what
I'm gonna be there for my kids
you know I'm not gonna let my
my
Hang-Ups right air quotes Hang-Ups or
um my disability air quotes disability
look like
something to where my kids can
experience Disneyland
you know what I mean like you know like
uh even though the loud fireworks
freaked me out the mass group of people
freaked me out you know I can choke it
down
because looking at them they can ground
at me because they're small they're
smiling you know if I'm if if I'm living
for my friends that got killed sometimes
it's easier
I'm not ready yet right Julian's not
ready yet but if I can think about what
would it be like for Cody to be at
Disneyland or what what would it be like
for you know uh Anthony mattioni to be
there or what would it be like for Jason
Calo to be there you know what I mean
like and these guys are real dudes man
and like sometimes it's easier sometimes
it's easier to live for somebody else
man for the time being give yourself
some space man you know what I mean
because
um the idea is not to end it right it's
not to give yourself a permanent
solution to a temporary problem
you know you can't you know what I mean
I like you know there's there's you know
so I mean especially the holidays man
it's so hard on people Doug you know you
got people you know committing suicide
and there's nothing wrong with that dude
it's just that like
I wish that
I wish that they would ask for help yeah
or or I wish that they would have found
an anchor that to live for you know I
mean be like hey man you I'm too weak
right now I can't go through this
anymore
I'm gonna live for somebody else wow you
know what I mean yeah I'm gonna let them
carry me even though if they're not even
here on this physical plane anymore
they're in they're in the spirit world
you know yeah I'm gonna live for them
I'm gonna live for them dude you know
what would they you know what would they
want you know
well they might want a slice of
chocolate cake okay let me eat a Chuck
because they're inside me man I carry
them in my heart
right they might yeah what they wouldn't
give today to pick up their kid what
they wouldn't give today to look over at
their wife and smile what they wouldn't
give today to uh laugh that maybe their
steps getting a little bit slower or
their boat their bones Creak when they
reach for something just little things
like the littlest things
man yeah man or you fall down dude or
you fall down like laugh at yourself dog
yeah laugh at yourself dog like stop
taking yourself so seriously man
you know what I mean like it it it it's
a struggle man it is
it is man
um Julian yeah I would look I would love
because we're in Southern California
we're not too far dude we'd love to you
know let's figure it out we'll do
something in the new year let's come in
and I would just love to go through this
and and think about some more stuff man
and I think that that's just a powerful
note it's like you know those moments
when you can't live for yourself to be
unselfish enough and perspective
adjustment enough say well who can I
live for even if it's for the next five
minutes to get me over that hump
because sometimes it's just that hump
it's just that [ __ ] hump man dude
dude so like uh one of the biggest
things that I learned is that like the
idea of forever
that like no matter how much water I
poured on my legs bro it weren't going
to grow back you know what I mean
and sometimes even to this day bro like
12 years after
it's so heavy to think about forever
but if I just say you know what man
you're in amputee today
just focus on today
you know what I mean like that's all
you're doing man you know like
don't worry about you may not even live
for 40 years you may not even live 50
years dude like but you're living right
now man and who do you want to live for
today and dedicate that day for somebody
else man you know one step at a time man
we're not one step at a time that's a
horrible but you know what I'm saying
bro damn
right yeah
yeah dang boy you got them lifters on
baby damn dog
you know what I mean
yeah bro
damn bro you that Flamingo baby you got
them [ __ ] going cuz
you know man you know
um but look man Merry Christmas to you
dude we'll connect and um yeah I would
say sometime in January maybe late
January I don't want to put an exact
date on it but I'd love to do it in the
spring and just get you in and learn a
little bit more about the experience and
stuff so we're gonna have we're gonna
start doing a few more episodes in the
in the new year next year overall so
it'll give us a little bit more space
man but thanks for your service man
thanks for your perspective dude I think
it's something that we all uh needed
today so thank you
bro uh for people like you dog for
people you know dude like honestly man
like
um I would do it again man 100 dude when
when that dude said that he get hit by
that train bro
you know I related to that because it's
true even if I knew the outcome
and I you know everything played around
the same dude I'd be like yeah let's go
send it
because
um everything everything's better dude
now
you know what I mean like everything's
more fruitful everything's more vibrant
everything you know what I mean because
you know when you when you tickle that
Death Angel you know what I mean it's
right there ready to collect dude
damn what else what else do you have to
be afraid of Doug you know what I mean
thank you man thank you for your time
brother Merry Christmas to you man
uh thank you guys for everything man
thanks for the opportunity oh yeah you
bet dude this has been really this has
been man this couldn't have been more
perfect for us and and just for the
audience and I think just for
man I uh
I I don't know you know you
I don't know how you could do it's hard
to say to somebody man like
you're doing this really well
oh dog
you know man you're doing this really
well it's effective you know uh
so
you know thank you
oh Doug yeah
you know dude like uh just real quick
man I mean
uh it's all those people do that like
have helped me
that have given me their best
and like
help put me back together you know
I feel like I absorbed that yeah
and so it's like I'm here let's have fun
dude yeah let's do something dude you
know let's go you know I don't know
let's live dog let's live let's live
baby
how do you say let's live in Spanish dog
how do you say it Vive hey
I think so man I think it's uh uh damn
you don't know Spanish dog
this is the problem bro see this is the
problem dude all white people are
teaching us [ __ ] Spanish and then
Mexican kids they don't the second
generation they don't even learn it
dog I'm like fifth generation
oh you got it then bruh
yeah we've been here a long time dang
baby we'll be in Benito's dude I'm glad
that you're here I'm glad that I'm here
I'm glad we get to walk this Earth at
the same time man we'll Circle up with
you bro Merry Christmas Julian Torres
thank you so much for your service
love you bro you guys be good man gang
gang you want Mente baby gang gang
man
um thank you
thank you to everybody that served uh
thank you everybody that that pays
attention
um thank you to everybody in the world
that uh
uh I don't know you know it's and you
know this these are the moments that I
live for
these are the moments that uh
that I live for
they really are
um
just those moments when you feel when
you just
when you and somebody else somebody you
don't even know y'all are on the say
y'all are standing on the same [ __ ]
molecule
of respect and compassion
and understanding
and hope
um
you know we are lucky
we are lucky to be able to feel that
uh in this world
um
Merry Christmas to everybody
you know Merry Christmas and recognize
there there are people out there that
are keeping uh us in a place where we
can enjoy
and uh
and celebrate
um and that we have good reason too
um
love you guys uh thank you Julian Torres
yeah it'd be great to have you come in
brother we will figure that out
uh thank you to everybody that called
um
and we can't wait we can't wait we can't
wait to start living
you know even if it's hard
uh you guys be good to yourselves baby
and stay alive and stay living baby I'm
more upstairs
gang son we're off next week uh we're
taking a break
um and we will be back in the new year
uh we're excited
um we're hopeful and
um we're gonna keep going
because that's what we do
you guys be good to yourselves baby you
deserve it gang